-This is so fun.
Thank you for joining us.
Guys, here's how
the game works --
In front of us,
we have two envelopes
containing confessions,
okay?
In one of the envelopes
is something
that actually happened
to us in real life,
and the second envelope
is a lie.
Once you've read
your confession,
the other two players have
60 seconds to interrogate you,
and then they each have to guess
whether you've been lying
or telling the truth.
Okay.
We'll take one turn each.
-Sure.
-So, let's get started.
Jennifer, you go first.
John, which envelope should
Jennifer open?
-Um, two?
-Yes.
-Two.
-Yeah, I'm feeling two, as well.
-Envelope two.
-Interesting, interesting.
-It just says "pregnant."
[ Laughter ]
It just says "not pregnant."
-Interesting.
-I once took an Ambien
before filming a scene
in "The Hunger Games."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Okay.
-Was the scene --
Were you sleeping in the scene?
-No.
-You were not? You were awake?
-No. In fact, I was dancing.
-You're supposed to be --
Dancing in "The Hunger Games"?
-Were you fighting
in this scene?
Was it a fight scene
that you slept through?
-No. No.
Do I just answer in yes or no?
Can I elaborate?
-Yeah, you can elaborate.
Sure.
-Okay.
Yeah, that wouldn't be fun.
No.
[ Laughter ]
It wasn't a dance scene.
No, I just -- I woke up,
and, I, um...
-Did you do it by mistake?
-Yeah. I thought it was
something else.
-As a confession, is this --
-It was normal to take. Anyway.
-If this is true,
is this going to cause you
legal problems with the studio?
-Um...
The movies are done?
[ Laughter ]
-That's not how the law works.
-Yeah.
-It's all about "Star Wars" now.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That's fine.
-No? Okay, interesting.
So you took it,
but did anyone know?
Was anyone around you
when you took this?
-No.
-Well, just --
[ Buzzer ]
This is tricky.
This could go either way for me.
-What was that sound?
-Oh, that's the -- that's
my cellphone, I'm sorry.
I'm getting a call.
I'll get it later.
What do you think?
-It's plausible.
-Yeah.
-It's reckless.
-Yeah. Oh...
-I kind of like it.
If it's not true,
I am gonna be very sad.
I'm saying it's true.
I'm gonna say...
You're that much good -- I think
you're that good of an actor
that you could probably --
-Definitely take your time more
with this decision.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, how long?
-No, no, no, no.
-I say it's true.
-It's true.
-Yes!
-Oh, wow!
-Yes! Yes!
-Unfortunately.
-Oh, no, no, no!
-Did anyone know?
-Forget the rest of this.
-I know.
Forget these, yeah.
-We're done, we're done.
-We have to move on.
-Yeah, okay.
-Okay.
Here we go. My turn.
Which envelope, Jennifer?
-Liar!
-No, I can't say liar.
-The first one.
-First one.
[ Sighs ]
♪ Da-da-da-da-da-da ♪
I once wrote a song called
"Am I Doing It Wrong?"
and offered it free of charge
to Sir Paul McCartney.
♪♪
-Okay.
-What year?
-This year.
-Oh, this year.
-What was Sir Paul's reaction
to the offer?
-Would you like
to hear the song?
-No, what was his reaction
first.
-I don't doubt
that you have a song.
-Yeah. I want to see --
-How did you get it
to Paul McCartney?
-Well, I'm a giant fan of his,
and I think we've kind of become
kind of friends.
It's one-sided.
It's a one-sided friendship.
-Right.
-I have his cellphone number.
-Now I do want
to hear this song.
The one-sided-friendship song
that you threw into his face.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Drumming with hands ]
[ As Paul McCartney ]
♪ Am I doing it wrong? ♪
[ Crowd clapping rhythmically ]
-So you sent that to him?
-I left that on his voicemail.
[ Laughter ]
And I have -- Free of charge.
I have not heard back from Paul.
-So you called him?
-Yes.
-That's the part I don't buy.
-Oh, we're out of time.
-You would text him.
-What would the phonecall be --
-I don't care about the music.
I want to get back to
the phonecall.
-Yeah, I know.
-You texted him, didn't you?
-Both. Anyways,
the interrogation's over.
-I guess it's not true?
-No, I think it's true.
It's true.
-It's not true.
-I might as well get it wrong.
It's true.
-It's not true.
-'Cause it's pretty good?
-Yeah, it's good.
-It's, sadly, true, yeah.
-Yes! Yes!
-Well, I figured --
Well, what I figured is
nobody sends song ideas
to Paul McCartney 'cause
he's the greatest songwriter
in the history --
on the face of the Earth.
-So, then, that's what made you
think it was a good idea?
-Yeah.
You got something on your nose.
-Oh, is it a booger?
-Yeah.
-I felt it.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you feel it?
-I totally felt it.
-When did it shoot up?
-I was just like, "We're on TV.
There's no way a booger came out
of my nose on TV."
-You totally boogered out.
-Yeah.
Is it gone?
-It's totally gone.
Well, somewhere. It's somewhere.
-Is it gone? Is it gone?
-It's somewhere.
I don't know where it is,
but it's not there.
-[ Sighs ]
-It's gone.
-It's not on your nose.
-I told you!
-You called it.
Yeah, you called it.
-The lying really is a negative.
I felt it with my whole body.
-John -- John, yes.
It's down to you now,
right here.
-Okay.
-I will choose the envelope.
I'm gonna say I think
you're gonna be a good liar.
I just wanna say that
before we start.
-That's unkind, but sure.
[ Laughter ]
-No, in a good --
a friendly way.
-It's like English people
lied our way to an empire.
-Two.
Two, I will say.
-Number two?
-Yes, please. Yeah.
-Okay, what is this?
As a teenager,
I had a summer job
working in the kitchen
at Buckingham Palace.
-Not true.
-No way.
[ Laughter ]
Absolutely no way.
-Why? Hold on,
why would that not be true?
-Okay, how did you
get into the palace?
Where did you park?
-I didn't park.
I was a teenager.
I didn't have a car.
-Where did you rent
your skateboard?
-I flew in on an umbrella,
you racist.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-It was -- You could apply.
Schoolkids could apply
to work in the kitchen,
and I did that year.
So I lived nearby and I walked.
-What was your most
memorable meal that you made?
-I made the Queen
an omelet for breakfast.
-That is not true at all!
-Bah!
-This is so -- Bah humbug!
No way.
What kind of omelet?
What did she have in the omelet?
-It was a feta cheese omelet.
-No!
-The Queen would not eat
feta cheese.
-That is true.
[ Laughter ]
That is definitely true.
-No way, man!
-No, no.
Yeah, you're right.
She wouldn't eat feta cheese.
[ Laughter ]
-We busted you already.
-Yeah.
Yeah, you did.
It was a lie.
-That's where you lied.
-It was a lie.
She wouldn't eat feta cheese.
It's too Greek.
-Wait, what's your truth?
-My truth?
My truth was...
-What was your truth?
-Oh. At 19, I was thrown out
of a Tokyo sauna
for not being naked enough.
[ Laughter ]
-We don't need to hear that.
We don't need your context.
-Alright, thanks to
Jennifer Lawrence
and John Oliver.
[ Cheers and applause ]
True Confessions.
This is exciting, got the two of
you together, this is so fun.
Here's how this works.
In front of us are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true.
The other is a lie.
Once you read the confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then they have to come to
a unanimous decision --
is it the truth
or is it a lie?
-Bring it on!
-Alright.
Ryan, you'll go first.
-I go first.
Oh, I'm so excited, you guys.
-Which one?
-I'm going with --
I'm going with number 1.
-Okay.
-Right?
-Nice.
-I suppose. Yeah, sure.
-I think that's a good idea.
-This might be part of
the ruse already.
-"My mom once washed her hands
with a urinal cake."
-What's a urinal cake?
-Good question.
-Alright.
-I'm glad you asked me that.
-It's at the bottom of a urinal
when you go into the men's room.
-I don't visit those very often.
-It looks like
a little white puck.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-It might be confused with soap.
-Wait. But where was your mom
when this happened?
-She was at a funeral.
True story.
-How long ago was this?
-This was about two months ago.
-What?!
-Yep.
-Wait. Wait. So, your mom --
Your mom did what
with a urinal cake?
-It was an outdoor funeral.
There was, like, a little sort
of porta-potty-type thing
that had both the --
you know, the toilet,
and then it also had, like,
this little space-aged
kind of urinal thing that could
very easily be confused
as a sink with a little
puck in it.
Alright, it was me, not my mom!
No. No, no.
It was my mom.
And she accidentally used
the urinal cake,
thinking it was soap,
washing her hands.
-The urinal cake was up
by the sink?
-No, it was right in
this sort of
space-aged little urinal thing.
-In what city was this
porta-potty in?
-This was in -- just outside of
Vancouver, British Columbia,
Canada.
-Alright then.
Anything happens in Canada.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Alright.
-She washed her hands with it
and then left going like,
"Ooh, it smells funny.
This urinal cake is very --"
-Did she flush, like, thinking
that was the faucet
and just --
with the urine water?
-That I do not know, Jimmy.
-Alright, I'm going to say
I don't know.
-Yeah.
-I'm gonna say --
-If it did happen,
it's really funny,
but I don't think
it really happened.
-I'm going to say
that it's a lie,
because there's -- I don't know.
There's just some hesitation in
the facial expressions.
-I'm going to say it's a lie,
because I think if you went
to a funeral outdoors, I've
never seen a porta-potty
by the cemetery.
-Gotta go, you gotta go.
-By the cemetery?
Well, I mean, someone did go,
I guess, right?
-Yeah.
-True or lie?
-This is true.
-What?!
-Oh, my God! What?!
-True.
-Your mom did that?
-Oh, my God!
-In her defense,
a lot of people don't know
that that's a urinal cake.
-I didn't know what
a urinal cake was.
I actually would have made
the same mistake.
-Also, like, what kind of A-hole
calls it a cake?
-Yeah.
-Like, right?
-It sounds so pleasant.
-Alright. Here we go.
It's my turn. Here we go.
Alright.
Which envelope should I open?
1 or 2?
-2.
-I say 2.
-Let's mix it up.
-Yeah, 2.
-Why not?
-Here we go.
-Yes.
-"There is a bronze statue of me
at the bottom of the lake
next to Neil Young's farmhouse."
-What? That is so specific.
When was the statue made?
-The statue was made in
the early 2000s.
I'll tell you exactly what --
It was an award or something
that was actually given to me by
Regis and Kelly Ripa.
-Kelly?
-Back when Regis was on.
-Okay. Not Kathie Lee.
This is the Kelly era.
-No, this is "Relly."
-Wow. Okay.
-This is Regis and Kelly.
-What's the -- Sorry.
-They gave me an award,
like, some Jimmy Fallon award.
I did their show.
-And then they promptly
threw it in a lake.
-No. What happened was,
I was flying to Neil's,
'cause I was doing his
Bridge School benefit,
which is a great charity.
-Yep.
-And I was going with Lorne.
And we were going right --
I went right after I did
"Regis and Kelly,"
so I had my --
Everything was packed.
I had an actual statue of me
that they gave me, on the plane.
So when I landed,
I had this statue of me.
And it was just --
I thought it would be funny
to show it to people.
-And how did it end up
in a lake?
-Because everyone was
making fun of me
that I had a statue of myself.
-So you threw it in a lake,
like the Heart of the Ocean
in "Titanic."
You just let it go.
-Yes. Yeah, yeah.
"My Heart Will Go On."
-Yeah, yeah.
-I had a few...beverages, and
everyone was passing it around,
accepting the award
and all this bit.
-So, wait.
What was the size of the statue?
-And it was bronze.
-It was bronzed.
It was, like,
aluminum foil on plastic.
-It's next to a statue of
Neil Young at
Neil Young's farmhouse?
-No, I was at Neil Young's
farmhouse,
and I threw it in the lake.
-Is Neil Young aware of this?
-Yeah, he was there.
-He's there?
-I'm going to say -- This
actually sounds true to me.
It doesn't sound too crazy.
-I'm gonna go with --
Camila's right.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-True. Okay, let's do it.
-It never happened.
I made it up.
-Oh! I was there!
-Wait.
-I made it up. I know.
-Oh!
-I've never been
to Neil Young's house.
That is the best acting of --
You've seen my movies.
You've seen my movies, right?
I mean, this is the best acting
I've ever done.
-Yeah, what are you doing?
I'm terrified of you.
-Camila, I love you.
It's your turn to go.
-Alright.
-I think number 1, right?
-I think number 1 for sure.
-Number 1. Alright. Okay.
Let's see.
-Let's see. Alrighty.
-I once lost -- this is your
friend -- Taylor Swift's cat.
-You once lost her cat?
-You lost her cat?
-I lost her cat.
-This is a big deal.
-Would you like to hear
the story?
-Yes.
-So, we were on
tour together last year.
I was opening for her
on her Reputation Stadium Tour.
-Mm-hmm.
-And she basically --
She asked me to babysit her cat.
Her cat kind of had, like,
a weird little
stomach-infection thing.
She was gonna go do
a meet and greet.
We were hanging out
in the dressing room.
I'm taking care of her cat.
Somebody from my team asked
me to do something.
I leave the door open.
The cat, Meredith, sneaks out,
is nowhere to be found.
-Yeah.
-Hours pass,
and nobody can find the cat.
-Yeah.
-Where are you? What city?
-It was also
in Vancouver, actually.
-This is already reeking like
a whole lot of bull.
-No, no, no.
It was in Vancouver.
-Oh, really?
-Ask me more questions.
-Yeah, yeah. Meredith.
I love that you threw in
the name Meredith.
-Everybody knows that cats are
banned in Vancouver.
-That's not true.
-Wait. So, wait.
So, the cat's sick.
That's when she asked you
to babysit the cat?
-Well, it's not like she was
like, "Please babysit the cat."
I was already hanging out with
her in the dressing room.
-And what was the cat like?
The cat's sick.
Is it moving around
or is it laying there?
-And she was like,
"Take my cat with this
unpredictable stomach issue
and enjoy it for a while."
No. Really?
-No, I mean, the cat was --
You know,
answering your question about
the cat's activity,
it was just laying there.
That's why I did not expect for
the cat to leave the door.
-So, you're saying that someone
removed the cat from the --
-No. I'm saying I left
the door open.
I didn't think the cat
was going to go anywhere.
-Camila, don't give me this.
This is ridiculous.
I mean, now, who found the cat?
Who found the cat?
-One of her security guards.
It was literally --
-Which one?
I know all of her
security guards.
-Yeah. Was it Dan?
-No, was it Steve?
-Was it Gil?
-I don't know his name!
She has 13!
-A lot of holes in this story.
-Okay. And then the cat
was found in, like, one of
the seats of the golf cart.
I don't know the security
guard's name, okay?
I'm sorry. There's a lot.
-Is this true?
I think this is true.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I feel like it's true.
-Yeah, I think we broke her,
'cause she was --
-I know.
-I think what happened was --
we were being fooled
the whole time.
We were being played.
-She's also one question away
flipping the table.
-Yeah, that's true.
-You better say it's true.
-I'm gonna say true.
-True. Yes.
-This is false!
-What?!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Really?!
-How did you do that?
-No, no, no. Wait, wait, wait.
Did you actually
think it was true --
-Yeah. 100%.
-Because I feel like
I'm a terrible --
I came into this game
knowing I'm a bad liar.
-It was the golf-cart thing.
-You have a black belt in lying.
-Really?
-Yes.
-That was pretty great.
-Yes! We're liars!
We're good liars!
-Wait, don't do that.
You guys are the greatest.
-Amazing.
-Our thanks to Ryan Reynolds,
Camila Cabello.
That was good.